behind me as other Sciences superstars
they've all won Nobel prizes and I'm
here to them and some younger scientists
about the future of Medicine
some of its pretty surprising every year
on lindau island in germany large
numbers of nobel laureates and young
scientists meet a rare chance for nature
to make some films about the big
questions in medicine today to try to
get a picture of health
our first film looks at the elusive
virus which causes AIDS now I've been
hearing all about this patient from
Berlin who had a bone marrow transplant
and cured his HIV tell me a little bit
more he had cancer and what actually
happened is that the cells that they
transferred to replaces bone marrow they
were from another person who had a
certain specific genetic mutation the
mutation called ccr5 prevents HIV from
infecting cells so they whacked out all
of his immune cells and replaced them
with the donor cells and he stayed
negative for HIV
ever since I wonder how you felt when
you first realized that the HIV had
disappeared in that patient first of all
but it'd be your lifetimes achievement
if if we can really find a cure or a
vaccine
oh I mean that will be a relief for me
it's really a dream but the most things
that I'm really concerned about
re-emerging HIV epidemic is that for me
will be a terrible failure and I'm I'm
really worried about that our second
film The Long Goodbye faces the
challenges of aging what is the life
expectancy of the world population today
is it 50 60 or 70 years
please answer a B or C about life
expectancy you answered let me see ah
this is the right answer you see why you
think that population will age because
life will be longer because you don't
know how long they already are the world
has been immensely successful in
removing early death especially among
children the aging of the world
population is driven by something else
than longer
but even scientists haven't understood
what do you think the challenges are of
having a globally aging population can
we afford to treat some conditions that
are extremely expensive to treat that
don't have enough benefits you have to
bite the bullet I mean we have to be
realistic about it and that's the
trouble we aren't realistic about it was
sentimental and we say everybody has a
right to life and so on which is true
but you can't afford to preserve every
life we don't have enough money for our
third film we ask if the side effects of
drugs are inevitable I've been talking
to lots of students about whether we
might ever be able to design drugs that
have no side effects I don't think that
drugs have side effects okay
I think drugs actually have effects side
effect is our interpretation of what we
didn't want to happen a bit like weeds
in the garden they're just ants and
unwanted places exactly yes actually
drugs
very largely are selectively poisons
well if drugs are poisons is there a way
we can test the effect on our bodies
before we take them if we want to make
embryonic like sub cells from your
material we can do that we simply take
your skin cell and grow those embryonic
cells and then make them into all
different types of tissue and then what
we can then do is come in and start
testing drugs against all those
different tissues it's one of the most
exciting technologies right now is the
fact that you can take different tissues
that are made from these stem cells and
we can actually start to build different
organs on a ship so you're building a
miniature lung in a miniature liver and
looking at how medication for one is
affecting the other robot and our last
film as difficult questions about the
war on cancer it's 25 years since you
won your prize and what progress have we
made in cancer in that time well we've
made extraordinary progress I mean the
landscape is unrecognizable compared to
where we were in 1976 we're just not
there yet
now at least we know
the fundamental underpinning and that is
the malfunction of genes we do now have
a fundamental understanding we know
where to look what's it like to work
with patients who are facing these
cancers be they on the treatable side or
less treatable I find it very
challenging my motivation itself to
become a physician was initially because
we had cancer run within the family
instead of grieving for years and then
investing all this energy into the
sadness I just decided that I want to
tunnel all of this energy into research
cancer does not only affect the patient
it's a disease that affects the entire
family and friends around it and it
really is a disease with no boundaries
so it's in a way clearly a complicated
disease but it's not unresolvable I mean
if you really put a lot of effort into
the story then we have a chance to do
something but we can only prevent these
diseases if we understand food is a type
of way and mechanism by which the
disease is emerging
we're here in lindau with 37 nobel
prize-winning scientists 600 young
researchers 12 of them sponsored by Mars
and people want to hear all about the
science that Mars has been doing well
the great thing about coming to lyndale
is that we get to spend time with
sciences rock stars you aware that
you're in the presence of greatness and
the more that we can find ways of
engaging some of the finest minds in the
world to helping us solve some of these
grand challenges and then there's got to
be some great stuff in
one of the things we do is we like to
have a lunch where we basically spend
time with the young scientists that
we've sponsored to come here and tell
them a little bit about the kind of
company that we are the kind of work
that we do and why we passionately
believe that these great scientists
should consider coming to a company like
Mars for a lifetime career in fun
science that will make the world a
better place
best part really is that you get to
actually meet these young scientists who
will look at you in the eye and say this
is the best week of my life
it is Sigma the Nobel laureate and have
a conversation that is a gift so we have
a science breakfast which is the
opportunity for us to host a discussion
around a very meaningful area of
research of healthy aging so we have Liz
Blackburn who won a Nobel Prize in this
field and we put her together with a
group of young scientists in a forum
facilitated by ourselves let's think
about the huge amount of years that
human lives are right so I made a little
scale bar for you on this high-tech
thing here this is a time scale what's
the maximum lifespan over a worm that
goes from here to here right of a fruit
fly from here to here now things get a
bit better ok let's go all the way out
to a mouse all right keep going keep
going
ok we've got up to kindergarten we've
got decades and decades of life so the
science breakfasts are always great fun
highly interactive and a really good way
to have meaningful debate in an area of
public interest but also interest to
ourselves we're in middle age here so
maybe somebody's giving some diabetes
now I mean that's the thing it's not
just your lifespan there's perhaps years
of living with chronic disease I think
you get the point right I'm just
constantly struck by how we have to be
thinking in terms of enormous timescales
that these things are the world is going
to be facing an aging population we're
all gonna get older and there's gonna be
a lot more of us who are old how do we
deal with that helping young scientists
realize that they can work with somebody
and realize that these are problems that
the world has to solve and business and
science can do it together I think the
private sector can play a real role
because this sort of research that can
be done by a company that isn't
necessarily related to just the
quarterly bottom line is the kind of
research that's complementary to what
governments can find I think Mars is a
good example of that so we got 37 Nobel
laureates here and just over 600 young
scientists and if we can play our role
in catalyzing some of the magic
happening between those two groups of
people then we go away very happy
you